nos amis agriculteurs des agriculteurs
appellent à bloquer toute la France
êtes-vous d'accord avec eux depuis le
début de la semaine la colère des
agriculteurs ne cessent de monter ils se
mobilise contre la hausse des taxes et
des normes environnementales qu'il juge
trop lourde il y a Laurent Mariotte ti
qui a parlé qui a dit un truc très juste
bravo Laurent Mariotte vraiment qui fait
la manger ouais exactement ou bah oui
bah oui oui de nombreux barrages et
opérations escargot sont mis en place
sur d'importants axes routiers du pays
depuis quelques jours mais ces actions
paralysent de nombreux Français regardez
toutes les routes bloquées dites-nous
êtes-vous d'accord avec ce blocage des
agriculteurs ou pas oui non et dites la
vérité c'est pas la peine de faire
plaisir bien entendu
[Musique]
regardez Julien faut pas lâcherz je dis
à Julien Julien faut pas lâcher JulienC
qui est avec nous agriculteur séréalier
ouais qui est un garçon dont je voilà je
l'ai trouvé incroyable je voulais vous
le dire Julien vraiment et franchement
je vous dis ils ont le tous les
agriculteurs qu'on reçoit ici à chaque
fois sont des gens vraiment que que
j'aime profondément je le dis et qui
sont des gens qui ont la passion de leur
métier qui sont des gens qui qui j'adore
parce que ce sont des gens qui ils font
leur truc il s'occupent de rien pendant
des années ils ont fermé leur gueule
pendant des années on leur a tapé dessus
on les a laissé de côté ils ont fermé
leur gueule à un moment euh quand tu es
étranglé et que tu es étranglé de plus
en plus que les agriculteurs ça date pas
d'hier hein ou euh de d'un mois ou de
d'un an hein le leur problème hein ça
date je vous le dis moi depuis que je
fais de la télé euh j'entends parler de
tes problèmes ça fait peut-être 10 ans
que j'en entends parler et chaque année
on dit il y a une urgence maintenant
quand l'urgence elle a 10 ans là c'est
plus une urgence là c'est c'est c'est
limite ça c'est vital pour eux et vous
voyez le le nombre d'agriculteurs en
France ça a été une dégringolade c'est
nombre d'agriculteurs si on continue
comme ça on va se retrouver sans
agriculteur on manger on est compte ou
pas donc aujourd'hui aud'i aujourd'hui
voilà ce qui se passe c'est que je je le
dis il faut aider il faut aider ceux qui
travaillent je suis désolé il faut aider
ceux qui font qui ont toujours fait la
France et ceux qui ont toujours été les
les les ceux ceux qui sans agriculteur
je vous le dis ou mais les mecs sans
agriculteurs on fait quoi c'est les
jardiniers de la France exactement non
non mais non mais je vous dis donc moi
les gars comme Julien et tous les
agriculteurs qui nous regardent moi je
si je peux me permettre je le dis
aujourd'hui êtes-vous d'accord avec eux
bien sûr c'est pas évident pour tout le
monde tout le monde a un travail mais
moi je dis que toute la France doit se
mobiliser pour aider les agriculteurs
toute la France doit se mobiliser pour
eux et toute la France doit se dire que
les agriculteurs on est tous
agriculteurs act on devrait faire un
mouvement on est tous agriculteurs et
être tous derrière eux il faut que ça
bouge très vite alors j'ai vu que
Gabriel Atal le Premier ministre a dit
qu'il alla donné 10 mesures incroyables
très vite on espère que ça va aller plus
que vite parce que chaque jour qui passe
c'est ça devient un cauchemar pour nos
amis agriculteurs et je vous le dis la
question de ce soir bien sûr il y en a
qui sont pas d'accord et on va on va les
écouter bien entendu parce que il y a
des Français aussi qui sont comme vous
mais les agriculteurs je vous dis c'est
c'est des c'est c'est on doit tous être
derrière aujourd'hui il y a même pas de
débat c'est pas des c'est pas des
caprices c'est pas des mecs qui qui font
un caprice c'est pas des mecs qui qui se
disent tiens on va on va on va faire ça
parce que on gagne on gagne qui gagne
déjà très bien leur vie qui se dit ti on
on va faire chier le monde non pas du
tout ce sont des gars pour la plupart
qui sont étranglés la plupart des
agriculteurs
aujourd'hui ils sortent pas 1 € de leur
exploitation tous les mois donc comment
ils font ils sont obligés de vivre de
leur exploitation et ils sont obligés de
faire des efforts tous les jours et ils
sont étranglés alors aujourd'hui on l'a
déjà dit et et je le dis j'ai rien
contre les les les les les les normes
environnementales ou contre les
écologies c'est ce qu'on j'ai entendu
dire ici et là à un moment je le dis on
ne on peut pas faire plaisir à tout tout
le monde et à un moment pour moi la
priorité ce sont les agriculteurs la
planète c'est très important mais comme
je l'ai dit la France on est une
cacahuète hein c'est pas nous qui allons
sauver le monde croyez-moi donc avant de
penser de sauver le monde sauvons nos
compatriotes et sauvons les agriculteurs
je pense que c'est la la priorité elle
est là et l'urgence elle est là merci
Julien en tout cas d'être là vous
bloquez le pays parce que vous en avez
marre en fait c'est pas les pauvres je
le dis je c'est c'est je sais qu'il y a
des gens qui disent ouais ils nous font
chier mais ils nous font chier de quoi
un moment un moment ils ont tout essayé
ils ont tout fait ouais ouais un moment
ils disent B il faut là tous les jours
tous les jours tous les matins on se
lève on va bosser on se pose pas la
question il faut partir le matin faut
travailler faut produire on est là pour
bah vous nourrir tous les matins si on
se lève c'est pour vous
euh nous on aimerait bien aujourd'hui
bah savoir vivre de cela parce que le
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui on
travaille on fait des heures il y a pas
de limite jamais jamais jamaisama ça
fait des années que vous baissez la tête
et que vous allez bosser vous on nous
met des règles tous les joueurs des
nouvelles de plus en plus compliquées
l'écologie tout le monde en parle mais
nous on la vit on l'a fait parce que
l'écologie nous on l' on l'a fait tous
les jours on peut pas faire plus propre
que ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui la France
on est le pays où il y a le plus de
règles sur sur nos production c'est pas
possible et on se permet aujourd'hui
d'importer tout et n'importe quoi on
fait des importations déloyales euh il y
a pas de limite euh on prend aujourd'hui
de tout sans regarder en face de ça les
contraintes si c'est les mêmes que les
nôtres et ça c'est un gros problème
comment vous faites aujourd'hui pour
accepter de rentrer du sucre qui n'a pas
les mêmes contraintes que le sucre que
l'on produit chez nous en France on
s'est battu il y a 2 ans pour sauver le
sucre français on s'est battu avec les
néonicotinoïdes on nous a dit les
nononicotinoïdes il y a un problème avec
les abeilles on a dit ok on fait ce
qu'il faut on l'enlève et aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qu'on fait on rendre du sucre
de d'autres pays notamment de l'Ukraine
sans droit de douane dans l'Europe voilà
comment tu veux qu'ils s'en sorte les
gars voilà c'est ça c'est impossible un
moment donné nous on a des contraintes
qui c'est important que tu le dis Julien
parce que nous nous je te le dis on n
pas au courant de ça mais non on est pas
au courant de ça je pense que le
français aujourd'hui il aait bien demain
matin ça va remettre un sucre dans son
café sans se poser la question s'il
vient de France ou surout et surtout il
aimerait même bien mettre un sucre
français dans son café qui sera au même
prix que le sucre ukrainien ouais bah
c'est ça aussi l'histoire parce que
aujourd'hui les Français il sont au MO
la même marche pourricul ouais
exactement mais ils sont tous étranglés
donc les Français aujourd'hui on peut
pas leur en vouloir eux ils vont comme
j'ai dit ils vont faire leur cours et
ils essayent de trouver le moins cher
déjà qu's ont du mal à faire le panier
de course parce que déjà tout c'est
devenu n'importe quoi entre
l'électricité l'inflation aujourd'hui tu
déjà si tu arrives à avoir de la lumière
et manger un bout de pain non mais sans
rigoler fais on a l'impression que tu es
riche non mais je je le dis et et et les
agriculteurs en fait ça c'est des trucs
qu'on sait pas et aujourd'hui les
agriculteurs je le dis ils sont
étranglés il y a des normes on on est on
a ils se mat pas ils se battent pas avec
les mêm les armes que les autres on a
une surtransposition des règles vous
avez l'Europe qui met un cadre donc qui
est qui est déjà important et la France
remet toujours une contrainte
supplémentaire par-dessus le cadre
européen est-ce qu'il faut continuer
dans ce sensl je pense que non il a un
moment donné il faut arrêter faut pas
avoir une Europe à deux
vitesses la France aujourd'hui il faut
qu'elle prenne une décision je sais pas
si Monsieur Atal est sourd ou malentend
fond avec vous qu' vous laisser pas Tom
en tout cas on attend qu'il donne de
vraies réponses il pourrait peut-être
nous contacter venir vers nous nous on
l'attend on est sur la 13 si si Gabri
nous nous nous regarde Gabriel il il
peut se déplacer il peut venir vous voir
je suis sûr que je suis sûr qu'il
faudrait qu'il viennne vous voir ce
weekend sur la 1 N on va Ren lâcher ce
sera incroyable et je suis
sûrfend mais aujourd'hui Julien je le
dis je pense qu'il faut vraiment lancer
aussi même le hashtag nous sommes tous
agriculteurs pour moi je le pense
vraiment je pense vraiment qu'on doit
tous être derrière vous et et limite
qu'on se qu'on se mobilise nous même
dans l'émission faudrait qu'on fasse un
truc tous les jours tant que ça bouge
pas voilà tous les jours à partir de
lundi on va faire quelque chose tous les
jours pour vous et on va essayer de
mobiliser le plus de Français possib
ible et j'aimerais qu'à partir de lundi
tous les jours on dise un truc qui se
passe pour les agriculteurs un truc dont
on est pas courilà vous n avez c'estce
que en fait nous on est on est au
courant on n pas au courant de tout ça
on est au courant de rien donc forcément
on dit bah tiens et les mecs qui nous
font chier on est sur la route oua bah
on est bloqué bah ouais on est bloqué
mais eux ça fait des années des années
qu'ils peuvent même pas se déplacer
parce qu'ils ont même pas de ilss ont
ils arrivent pas à s'en sortir non mais
c'est vrai donc aujourd'hui noususs on
peut pas se déplacer une semaine de de
semaines il faut il faut tous c'est par
la mobilisation de tous les Français
derrière les agriculteurs que le
gouvernement va bouger au plus vite et
vraiment on ne peut pas les laisser
tomber et de toute façon il faut bien se
dire les choses si on bouge aujourd'hui
et si on fait ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui
qu'on qu'on sort de nos exploitations
pour aller manifester c'est pas pour
rien c'est vraiment parce que on a
besoin que ça change bien sû c'est pas
pour faire chier les Français non non on
n pas là pour ça on met tout en place
pour essayer de pas trop embêter le
monde alors il y a des dérapages parfois
je vois des choses qui sont pas
forcément tolérables mais bon c'est
comme ça je suis désolé euh à un moment
donné il faut que ça bouge euh voilà il
faut qu'on soit là il faut qu'on vous
montre ce qui va pas parce que c'est
aussi notre devoir mais il faut qu'à
côté de ça il y ait des vrais
changements que le gouvernement fasse ce
qu'il a à faire c'est ça évite évites V
on est
tous merci ma chérie j'aimerais avir
juste des des noms Julien juste pour
savoir pourquoi vous répondez non par
exemple vous Daniel c'est vous n'êtes
pas d'accord avec les agriculteurs non
non non mais qui appelle à bloquer la
France moi moi je suis à à 1000 % pour
là tout ce que vous avez dit et pourtant
je mets non parce que je ne peux pas
entendre on va monter à Paris on va
bloquer la France parce qu'on a mais
vous avez les meilleures raisons du
monde j'écoute depuis 3 4 jours c'est
incroyable ce qu'on vous fait vivre je
suis à 1000 % d'accord mais on ne peut
pas dire on va bloquer la France parce
que bloquer la France c'est bloquer les
Français en plus votre situation elle
est catastrophique mais moi par exle je
connais bien le milieu des infirmières
et des aides à domicile c'est honteux ce
qu'on leur fait vivre donc en janvier ça
va être vous en février ça va être les
infirmières qui vont dire on bloque la
France en mars ça va être les pompiers
qu'on caillass pour voilà donc moi c'est
pour ça que j'ai mis nom mais ça
n'empêche que évidemment si on peut
faire des
actions plus
problème juste je vais te dire je vais
prendre la défense de de
Julien les gars les gars un moment ils
savent plus quoi
faire fa ça fait des années qu'il disent
on en peut plus on peut plus ils et ils
ont continué à aller travailler le matin
ils on Contin oui et puis quand tu te
lèves le matin que tu vas bosser et que
le soir quand tu rentres chez toi tu
sais pas si tu vas avoir de quoi mettre
demain à manger dans l'assiette de tes
enfants avec l'argent de ce que tu
gagnes de ce que tu as fait dans ta
journée vous vous levez tous les matins
là tout autour de moi je pense que vous
vouz tous les matins en sachant à la
base combien vous gagnerez à la fin du
mois ouais ça je pense qu'aujourd'hui
chaque Français qui a un emploi c'est le
dire quand le premier jour il se lève il
sait dire à la fin du mois combien il
gagnera bien sûr moi aujourd'hui je me
lève le matin mais je sais pas combien
je gagnerai à la fin de l'année et et
même pas à la fin de la journée certains
jours on perd de l'argent c'est le cas
en ce moment oui Jean-Michel ou je
comprends même pas qu'on ne puisse pas
être solidaire la compassion enfin une
infinie tendresse pour les agriculteurs
qu'on sait que nous depuis ce matin
quand on s'est levé dans notre
appartement douillé parisien et ce soir
le moment va se coucher il y a deux
agriculteurs qui seront suicidés seront
pendus à un arbre parce qu'ils ont pas
réussi à faire vivre leur famille qui
seront surendetté et cetera voilà moi
mon grand-père était paysan il est mort
il même pas il a jamais pris un jour de
vacances il a travaillé tous les jours
de 5h ou 6h du matin jusqu'au soir tard
la nuit tombée et cetera donc j'ai vu un
peu les conditions et je trouve c'est un
moment quand on en peut plus et il y a
pas d'autre possibilité que de le
bordel parce qu'il y a que comme ça
qu'on a entendu malheureusement France
donc moi je suis d'accord avec eu ils
veulent se faire ex problème c'est mais
mais c'est pas je le dis c'est pas les
agriculteurs ils sont réveillés là il y
a 2 semaines et ils ont dit on va
le bordel dans la France
Ann essay on est passé par le par le
cursus normal on é gentil mois de
janvier on a retourné les
panneaux même au MO de décembre on a
retourné les panneau c'est on était
sympa on a dit allez on fait un petit
mouvement on verra bien peut-être que
l'État peut-être que le gouvernement à
un moment donné va nous dire quelque
chose va faire un changement on a rien
vu venir exactement donc à un moment
donné quand on parlotte bah je suis
désolé mais il faut que tout le monde
accepte de parler autour de la table et
donc en bougeant bah c'est bizarre tout
d'un coup il y a des mesures qui se
prennent il y a des choses qui avancent
et on espère alors c'est de la mesurette
alors pour le bio il y a eu des choses
assez concrètes mais quand on voit le
reste bah il y a beaucoup de questions
euh faut voir ce que ça va donner moi
pour l'instant je suis désolé mais ça me
donne pas envie de décolérer ça me donne
pas envie de m'arrêter dans le mouvement
et tant qu'on aura pas réellement ce que
l'on demande je vois pas pourquoi on
arrêterait faut que vous vous battiez
avec les mêmes armes que les autres
après je vous rejoins dans une chose il
faut se tenir des limites faut pas faire
n'importe quoi on n'est pas là pour vous
tenir en otage mais bon pour l'instant
le mouvement est très populire donc non
mais évidemment qu'on a de la compassion
tout le monde c'est une certitude et
tout le monde est derrière vous moi j'ai
mis non parce que la ma réserve en fait
ce serait de dire mais comment vous
allez encadrer et comment vous allez
gérer le le problème des débordements et
en plus c'est la solution du désespoir
et comme disait Daniel il y a beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de professions qui
sont dans le désespoir donc si en France
on se rend compte qu'en fait régler les
problèmes c'est bloquer la France vous
n'êtes pas les seuls à à le faire vous
n'êtes pas les seuls en même temps
finalement à trouver cette solution de
blo complet et puis de dérapage quand on
dit en fait c'est l'appel au bordel
c'est pas l'appel au bordel j'imagine
que tout le monde tous les agriculteurs
ont envie que ça se passe dans le calme
mais vous savez comment c'est et comment
ça va dégénérer forcément et que si
cette solution là en fait cette méthode
là elle fait que les choses vont changer
parce que effectivement ça fait 10 piges
même plus que ça et et et on le savait
on savait qu'il y aurait des mouvements
sociaux après le confinement après le
covid après les gilets jaunes on savait
qu'à un moment donné ça all et moi ma
crainte c'est que je ce soit la seule
solution finalement et je me dis mais
dans pourquoi on va vivre quels vont
être dét bien plus importants que ou